fifty-year-old Sanjeev go heels children
are his pride and joy if all goes well
his son will be accepted at the Music
Conservatory life has been good to him
he's a partner in a prestigious
architectural firm he's close to his
children and his health is holding up
I've been privileged and now I can give
back something that's the sort of the
idea that really drove me and this is
such a life-changing thing for somebody
you know you're giving somebody a new
lease of life a new life and if I'm able
to do that safely why not gore hell
happened to see a TV report about
voluntary kidney donors and couldn't get
it out of his head the more I listened
the more the idea of being able to
donate a kidney to a stranger took took
me over it was it was an idea that was
planted and I didn't pay much attention
to it but I kept thinking about it he'd
witnessed the suffering caused by kidney
disease one of his relatives had to
undergo dialysis and eventually died due
to lack of a donor the coils come
originally from Gujarat India people
from the Indian subcontinent tend to be
prone to kidney problems but there are
very few compatible donors in Britain it
was one more reason for Goyal to stand
by his decision his children supported
the idea for three years now he's been
living with only one kidney he's still
perfectly healthy but like all kidney
donors he has to watch his weight to
reduce the risk of getting diabetes once
a year he goes for a follow-up exam at
London's Royal Free Hospital which
specializes in transplants
thank you looking good I'm feeling well
I'll see you again how did give you
indeed yes first Catherine O'Malley is a
contact person for potential kidney
donors among them are many pensioners
age is not a factor only the donors own
health if they hit get to the stage
where they come in for a full day of
tests one of the tests we do is to check
the kidney function and if the kidney
function is good enough then yes they
were happy to go ahead and the oldest
one in the UK to donate was an 83 year
old Ben Lindsay was the surgeon who
removed goyal's kidney surgeons are
always slightly anxious because we're
operating on patients who don't
technically need an operation it's very
different to fixing a problem you know
someone with a cancer or some other
circulation problem and so physically we
can only make these patients worse the
cut there that's healed nicely just
health isn't the only requirement for
donating a kidney each case is carefully
vetted to prevent organ trafficking the
hospital has to obtain a special license
for each transplant and then your camera
port in the two instruments nicely
healed so they've passed what we call an
independent assessment and that's
somebody who has no interest in the
process who interviews the patient and
gets a feel as to whether they feel that
there's any coercion or any other
motivations or monetary exchange
implicated by the process and that is
not allowed and they will stop the
donation as a rule organ donations are
anonymous in one case diabetes patients
Marion pattinson wanted to know who had
saved her life she used to be constantly
tired now she's got her old energy back
as soon as I got the kidney the energy
was just there yeah mad daughter she
kept saying mum slow down slow down she
kept going cuz I've got that much energy
Marion waited four months for the call
telling her a donor had been found
neither her partner Nigel nor her
daughter was eligible now the donor
claire has a very special place in the
couple's hearts
she said is it done there's a very
exceptional lady to donate such a life
change in organ it's just fantastic
every year on the anniversary of the
transplant the two women get together to
celebrate I was going to get you through
so I thought I feel the responsibility
towards her and protect your place yes
yes I feel somehow i'm going to take
care of her now sort of see it is weird
it's a very special so relationship each
day i keep thinking you know I've got
somebody else's a piece of somebody
else's body inside mine you know and yes
I do take care of it as I say when I
mean Claire up she'll say how's my
kidney and yes we say yes it's fine
thank you your house they feast on
letters and burgers but stay away from
alcohol claire has stopped drinking I've
been given my health back I've been
given my life back through being given
me the help to stop drinking and in this
way I could give someone else a starting
life a new life neither of these donors
likes to talk a lot about their good
deed hardly anyone at the architecture
firm has any idea what Sanjeev go he'll
did conscious as well though I don't
want to be seen to be look I'm a
wonderful person look what I've done I
just saying do you know you can do this
it's relatively safe hey I only took two
weeks away and you've given something to
someone that very few people get an
opportunity to do around 6,000 patients
in Britain are still waiting for a new
kidney but voluntary donors are still
few and far between other potential
donors across Europe are showing
interest but the waiting lists
everywhere are long
you